Apple's iPhone event is finally
happening tomorrow and everything leaked
over the weekend yes these are all new
leaks and rumors that I'm going to show
you with the iPhone 14 lineup the new
Apple watch Pro Design revealed some new
details about the airpods Pro 2 and more
so let's get right into it now getting
started Mark German put out his preview
on Sunday talking about what we're
expecting the iPhone 14 the Pro Models
the airpods Pro 2 Apple watch Pro and a
couple of other Apple watch models with
an iPhone Hardware subscription which I
am personally excited for so let's get
right into what got leaked first of all
we have the new iPhone 14 Pros always on
display Behavior which was allegedly
revealed days ahead of the unveiling now
this looks crazy and was actually
revealed by somebody called Anonymous as
in the Mac Rumors forums with some
images showing you guys how it's gonna
work now this is crazy because I did not
expect parts of the photo to work on
always on as well and that's because
we're gonna have one Hertz display
refresh rate so you can see a little bit
of the wallpaper or the background
visible this is insane I can't believe
it's gonna work like this I'm so excited
for always on now getting into the next
rumor of course you guys know we have
that wide pill shaped cutout that we're
all now expecting but we could even have
the classic battery indicator on the 14
pro model which a lot of people really
like because they have this version
right now that some people really
dislike they don't like how it looks and
how you don't really know how much
percentage you have unless you really
look at it so that's going to be nice if
they also include the classic version
now we're also expected to get a larger
battery on the iPhone 14 pro alongside
the always-on display so that's going to
be nice I feel like the battery light
this year is going to be insane
especially since the refresh rate goes
down to one Hertz that's Gonna Save A
Lot and moving on Apple has considered
removing the SIM card slot from some
iPhone 14 models now this is an old leak
so we'll see if Apple actually goes
forward with it but one little piece of
evidence from Steve Moser on the softer
side is that Apple will give esim a
bigger push this time around with
carriers preparing to steer users toward
the digital embedded SIM cards rather
than physical ones so we'll see if we're
getting a big push this year or next
year hopefully this year now we did get
some new case leaks for the iPhone 14
pro showing the actual size of the
camera lenses themselves and they are
absolutely massive look at that this is
the current 13 Pro and look how massive
it is on the new one that is just mind
blowing to see on top of that we also
got the actual Apple silicon and leather
iPhone 14 and 14 Pro cases revealed as
well and these camera bumps are out
absolutely insane so these are some nice
looking colors man this iPhone is going
to be nuts in terms of the camera we
also got a leak from what it looks like
China with a spec sheet and we can
actually see some very interesting
details here first of all we have the
confirmation of iPhone 14 plus for the
larger size regular 14. we have the
display sizes we have the knits of the
display 1200 which is the same for the
Pro Models just like it is on the 13 and
a thousand again on the 14s we have
confirmation of a16 on the pros a 15 on
the regulars with six gigs of RAM for
each 48 megapixels for the camera as you
can see right here 12 still on the 14s
we have the weights right here 255 grams
for the iPhone 14 pro Max which is
actually pretty heavy because the 13 Pro
Max right now is 240 so that's 15 extra
grams on the Pro Max model but the
interesting thing is the battery sizes
right here 4323 is actually smaller than
the 13 Pro Max however the iPhone 14 pro
model is going to be getting bigger 3200
instead of
30.95 and interestingly the 14 plus is
going to have the largest out of the
lineup 43.25 and that's probably because
it has the smaller camera module so a
bigger battery can fit probably but here
is the jackpot right here it's saying
that the 14 pro models are going to
start with 256 gigs of storage right
here you can barely see at 256 and the
regular models surprisingly are going to
start with 128 which I personally did
not expect now moving on we have a rumor
in terms of the regular 14 and 14 plus
which are going to feature an enhanced
version of the a15 now of course we
already expected that because right now
the 13 Pro Models come with a 5 Core GPU
while the regular 13s have the 4 core so
basically the new 14 and 14 plus will
have that same five core GPU that we
currently only have on the pros and that
was of course expected now let's move on
to the Apple Watch series 8 Pro leaks
and this is absolutely nuts imagine boo
says that there will be two buttons
space at the top left should be the
speaker while the side button in the
digital Crown will remain almost
unchanged in the same position with the
screen likely being flatter now two
buttons instead of one that's what you
get for paying for the pro model but
check this out we have the new leaked
case designs for the Apple watch Pro
with the size of 49 millimeters
confirmed yes that's the case size right
now it's 45 as the biggest case size for
the series 7. 49 is going to be huge so
it's gonna be for some guys with some
big wrists that's for sure but check
this out look at this case we have the
speaker holes right there we have the
extra button on that side we have the
regular side button and a new crown with
this weird protrusion on the side which
I haven't seen before that is kind of
nuts there you go you can see the
speakers right there
man this is going to be crazy and once
again here we go another little
accessory case that's supposed to go
over it so it's kind of interesting to
see that side button right here the huge
crown and what looks to be a flat top
for the display and adding to that from
Sony Dixon we have two buttons yes
here's one there and one on the other
side this is kind of like a third-party
case and banned combo with a flat top
and of course this is from Danver we
have the new colors so we're gonna have
the blue we're gonna have this space
gray black this gold The Starlight
silver and apparently transparent which
will probably be like an accessory on
top but it looks like we have
confirmation of the actual colors for
this model and here we go from Imagine
boo we have a protective glass cover or
like a screen protector for the S8 Pro
and it's completely flat which is
awesome and that's basically going to
mean that the glass is going to be a lot
more durable and safe it's not going to
crack as easily as the current ones
because you have exposed glass going
over the edge being curved but this is
going to be flat on top so it's going to
be nice and protected and finally we
have a new photo that was leaked showing
off the size differences between the
models here's the current 41 millimeter
Series 7 and 8 then we have the 45 and
then boom 49 which is massive with very
thin bezels probably right here on the
display it is just going to be
absolutely huge and finally we have the
gold mine bombshell leak for the series
a pro check this out 91 mobiles leaked
the actual CAD file for the series 8 Pro
and this is crazy because this right
here it looks like the airpods max cup
where it kind of is rounded then it has
a lip that goes out towards the side for
a flat display glass but look at this
protrusion on the side man look at that
showing off this new super nice looking
crown and moving on it was also leaked
for Mark German that there's going to be
a new range of extreme sports style
bands so maybe even exclusive bands just
for the pro model to try to get you to
spend the extra money which it might be
between 800 and a thousand dollars as
the starting price and Ian Zelda went
ahead and started making renders of the
crown and this right here I mean this
looks insane it definitely looks Pro
almost looks like it's kind of sharp so
I think he made a new one as you can see
right here this looks a little bit less
treacherous there you go that's his idea
of what the crown could look like and
even better Mark German says that we
could have a new programmable side
button which you saw right here on the
side but that means you could basically
program it to do anything you wanted to
do bring up an app or bring up something
else which is going to make it very
convenient for the sports users out
there but here's the interesting thing
about these CAD renders of the Apple
Watch series 8 Pro this guy Graham Bower
says it looks like the design is missing
something like it's actually designed to
have a rubber shock absorbent case and
that's why the screen protrudes and the
buttons bulge what if he is right what
if Apple actually puts a case around it
to make it really rugged and secure and
safe and that'll kind of complete the
look of this and it won't make it look
like this bulges out too much that'll be
very interesting his idea was something
like this but this looks a little bit
too crazy for me I don't think Apple
will go that crazy with the design and
now finally just to imagine what it'll
look like LD vova made some renders as
you can see looks nice and clean and
from this angle look at that protrusion
look at that really nice Crown the side
button and the flat massive display with
very thin bezels and here's another one
from LD vova once again in a different
design man that looks nice and clean and
on top of that Mark German says that
there's going to be some pretty info
dense watch faces for Fitness metrics
specifically for the pro model so I have
a feeling a lot of people are going to
be impressed and buying that pro model
because I think it's going to be a huge
step up from what we have right now and
on top of that we're also getting some
reports that there's going to be a new
Apple watch model that is cheaper than
the Apple watch SE coming at the Apple
event of course the series 3 is going to
get discontinued completely but what I
think this means is that the new se2 is
going to come in at a lower price
probably at around
249 or something like that so a little
bit lower to try to get you in the door
and now finally let's move on to the
airpods Pro 2 which Mark German says are
going to be unveiled at the iPhone 14
event which I think makes sense because
they're going to come with a new feature
to support lossless audio and that's
going to depend on Bluetooth 5.2 and
some other features in combination with
the iPhone 14 models and now we also got
some CAD files of the actual airpods Pro
2 charging case with a couple of new
features visible you can see an extra
hole right here which looks like to be
the microphone you have the port and
some speaker holes so that way you can
use it with find my so it makes some
noise you can find it there's also this
weird little area right here on the side
which is kind of hard to explain however
Nine tech 11 talked about as they said
that the thing on the side of the case
is allegedly an accessibility feature
and not a lanyard holder which people
thought it would be it's apparently used
as a mic to enhance the sound of
surroundings for hearing impaired people
very very interesting and that may be
why we have these new case leaks where
you have an additional lanyard holder
thing on the side instead of being built
directly into the side of the airpods
Pro 2 case like these little two holes
right here you actually have the
connection on the outside which is quite
interesting now in terms of the actual
sound quality and microphone quality of
the airpods Pro 2 there are going to be
some benefits with a new Bluetooth LE
audio feature that's coming as you can
see we're gonna have improved audio
quality because the codec uses a higher
bit rate which I think is actually going
to be lossless with a new custom codec
there's going to be longer battery life
because lc3 is lower Power multi-stream
Audio which means it can create its own
Bluetooth stream for each side of the
airpods which could increase the actual
quality then you can connect many pairs
of air pods to an iPhone at once we're
talking multiple I don't know two three
four I'm not exactly sure and no
switching between iPhone and Mac
required because you could literally be
connected to both at the same time all
the time so that's some awesome new
features of Bluetooth LE that are coming
and now we also have some information
about the new Apple reality Pro AR VR
headset which is going to be apparently
the first of three headset devices from
Apple and Mark German did say to be
clear there's nothing about the Apple
headset coming this Wednesday despite
speculation that there's going to be a
one last thing or whatever we're not
going to hear about it until a little
bit later and he did add some new
information about a new patent from
Apple with them registering for an
additional name Optica which he thinks
is going to be a feature surrounding the
device's interchangeable prescription
Optics system so it's basically going to
work like prescription glasses so you'll
be able to see your surroundings with ar
without having to wear glasses alongside
the headset as well so I am extremely
excited for tomorrow's event I think
it's going to be a banger I think people
are going to be blown away by the iPhone
14 pro with its new features with always
on with the 48mb a pixel camera with 8K
60fps video recording and I think the
Apple watch Pro is actually going to be
the star of the show and I think a lot
of people are going to be buying that
model so if you're excited go ahead and
let me know down in the comments section
which one you're going to be buying
definitely click the circle about to
subscribe because we're doing a lot of
coverage this month with text September
so thanks for watching and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
thank you